Our experts and emotion interview will be with Dr. Margaret Clark on emotions
and relationships.
So Dr. Clark is a world renowned expert in close relationships,
both friendships and romantic relationships and emotions,
and in particular the ways people experience and express emotions within
relationships among her various distinctions.
Dr. Clark is one of the founders and former presidents of the society for
personality and social psychologists.
She has countless books and publications and has received numerous awards and
recognition of her accomplishments.
So I now turn to a very special experts in emotion interview with Dr. Margaret
Clark on emotions and relationships.
So what I'd love to start out speaking with you a bit is just what got you
interested in emotion in the first place?
Sort of how did it all start for you?
I can't say I was interested in emotion per se in the first place.
I think what I'm going to say is probably typical of a lot of researchers or
what happened was my first mentor research mentor happened to be interested in
emotions.
It was Alice Isen.
Um,
and so she invited me to get involved in research.
She was the one that decided it was on emotions.
I just went along for the ride.
Um,
so that had to do with how people's moods influenced their social behavior.
and then in reading the literature I got interested in it myself.
So kind of came across it serendipitously and Olay.
Absolutely.
Excellent.
And since then,
I mean you've really just pioneered a whole field of work trying to better
understand social relationships and the role that emotions might play.
So I'd love to just ask you a few questions about that.
Um,
so your current research has explored social emotions and I'd love for you to
say just a little bit about what is the social function of emotions and what,
what our social emotions really?
Well,
I think all emotions are social.
So sometimes people call emotions like guilt and gratitude and hurt,
um,
social emotions.
But in fact,
I think all emotions serve social functions.
So I got interested in this because after my initial work on mood,
I got involved in doing research independently on relationships.
And at some point I brought those interests together.
Um,
it's still the case,
I think in emotion research that people largely studied on an individual level.
They look at what causes emotion and a particular person,
how a particular person in isolation regulates their own emotions.
But emotions show on our face,
in our voices and in our postures for a reason.
I mean,
if it was all individual,
they wouldn't have to show.
Um,
but they do show and I think they show because they serve an important social
functions.
And the,
the most obvious one to me is that they convey information about our needs to
other people.
Um,
so if we're fearful,
we need someone to comfort us or get rid of the fear producing,
uh,
thing.
Um,
even happiness I think conveys something about needs.
It conveys sometimes that we don't have a need or sometimes that whatever it is
our partner is doing is that's making us happy,
should be continued.
Um,
the absence of happiness and that situation can suggest that maybe they ought to
stop whatever they're doing.
Um,
sometimes it's,
it's,
it's actual negative emotion,
but it can be just the absence of happiness.
Um,
so I think they serve the function of conveying our needs and desires to other
people.
Um,
but there's a problem with that and that's the all so conveyor vulnerabilities.
So what I'm particularly interested in is the fact that people are selective,
um,
and to whom they'll express emotions.
You want to express emotions to someone that actually cares about your needs and
desires.
Um,
and you don't want to express emotion to someone who's going to take advantage
of that knowledge.
Someone who doesn't care about your needs and desires.
It's that can be really sensitive,
like you're saying,
expressing emotions to other people.
Uh,
on the one hand,
and then measuring that in the laboratory on the other.
So,
so how do we really get people to express these vulnerable emotions in a way
that we can study it as scientists?
Sort of.
What are some of the challenges doing this as a researcher who studies social
relationships?
I actually think it's not so hard to get people to express emotion in the lab,
but perhaps it should be.
Perhaps people would be wiser not to express it.
But if you want to look,
you know,
if you want to induce an emotion and get people to express it or you have to do
is ask them to give an impromptu speech,
uh,
they'll express some emotion.
You'll see the nervousness.
Um,
people have done things like ask people to sing a silly song.
It,
it will make them embarrassed in no time and they'll blush.
So it's not so hard to get people to express it in the lab.
Um,
and then you can look at,
uh,
differences in the degree to which they express it and differences in how people
respond to them.
Hmm.
And it's interesting because you've really looked at relationships in the lab
and these fascinating ways and through this uncovered what seemed to be two
different kinds of relationships,
right?
Which you referred to as exchange versus communal relationships.
And I wonder if you could just tell us a little bit about what some of the most
exciting discoveries have been,
you know,
in trying to tease apart these two relationship types.
Well,
I've been studying for a long them for a long time.
And honestly,
it was most interesting in the beginning when people didn't really believe in
communal relationships.
So I've always thought the communal relationships exist in their relationships
in which people feel responsible for one another's needs.
Um,
and they,
uh,
act in such ways as to support the welfare of one another.
Um,
they don't keep track of benefits.
And at the time I began the work,
the view was that people were fundamentally selfish.
They kept track of things,
they were very economically oriented.
Um,
and so initially finding evidence that not everybody behaved that way was
exciting.
Now I think that view is,
you know,
much more widely accepted.
It's a little less excited now.
So,
um,
but what I'm interested in now is a,
one of the implications of communal relationships for expressing and even
experiencing emotion.
So I said just a bit ago that you will,
emotions conveyed needs.
So it makes a lot of sense to convey them to people who actually care about your
needs.
And so you should,
you should have more emotion expressed in that those kinds of circumstances.
You actually want us naturally suppress it when you're around people who don't
care about your needs.
Um,
and then includes people in what I,
I called exchange relationships where people feel no particular responsibility
for your needs,
but it's especially important when the person is actually your enemy or on the
other side of a negotiation or the person that you're playing poker with.
There's a reason why people talk about poker faces.
You're not supposed to express emotion in situations where other people can use
that information to your detriment.
So it's almost as if these different kinds of social relationships determine how
much we're going to express our,
like you said,
hold back and suppress slower feeling.
I think the evidence is very clear on that.
They do.
Um,
people express more emotion and communal relationships.
and uh,
I would argue that they also experience more emotion in communal relationships
for a number of reasons.
But one is that we know that expressing emotion,
talking about an emotional experience,
expressing it on your face and your posture,
uh,
elicits the emotion in you.
So I think it's not just that we express more emotion and communal.
I think that that also leads us to experience more emotionally communal
relationships.
And it also sounds like these relationships,
we might express emotions differently,
experienced them differently and also we'll be differentially attuned to the
welfare of other people depending on whether in one of these two kinds of
relationships.
Is that right?
That is right.
Um,
it's also the case that when people are willing to express emotion,
it appears to build these relationships.
So if I don't know you at all and I start to get to know you and I never express
emotion,
um,
what I'm doing is not providing you with an opportunity to take care of my
needs.
So I have to take a risk.
Um,
and it is a risk because you might be horrified when,
you know,
I express my sadness to you and you had no interest in responding to me and you
might run the other way.
Um,
but I think we do have to express emotion to find out who will be responsive to
our needs.
And we also have pretty good evidence that when you do that,
it builds relationships,
uh,
that expressing negative emotions,
nervousness,
anxiety,
uh,
in one study predicted how many friendships a college students formed in their
first semester at college and how much there,
how close they became to those people,
how much intimacy in terms of understanding,
validation and care,
um,
characterize those relationships.
And it also predicted how much support they're roommates gave them.
So if they express more negative emotion,
they got more help,
they became friends.
Interesting.
So it sounds like it's really especially important to show negative emotions.
It's less about showing positive emotions,
right?
In terms of getting people to feel close to you and want to support you.
Does that sound right?
Um,
no.
Yeah,
completely.
So you might think that it's all about negative emotion if you want to get
someone to support you.
But I actually believe that pause,
expressing positive motion is equally important.
So if I express happiness to another person,
um,
it does lots of things.
So if upon meeting you,
I express happiness,
that's probably the most common factor.
Determining whether,
you know,
I like you,
if I'm happy to see you as opposed to looking the other way,
which sometimes happens in our,
in our interaction.
It does.
So I think happiness is a queue.
You can take it as a cue that I like you.
I'm an established relationship is very important.
Um,
Q two when you should celebrate for the other person,
something great happens to me.
Um,
and I'm really enthusiastic.
I just got the perfect job that I always wanted.
Um,
if I express it to you,
you can engage in something Harry Reese called and also Shelly gable called
capitalization.
You can celebrate for me.
How do you know when you should do it?
You would know you should do it.
If I'm happy,
you should be happy for me if you're happy for me.
That bill's relationships.
So I don't think it's just expressing negative mood that uh,
negative moods or fear or sadness,
anxiety,
that's important for you to provide support.
But expressing happiness is equally,
if not more important for you,
providing support.
So it's that balance of expressing sort of all facets of our emotional being.
In a way,
both the positive and the negative.
Yes.
All facets.
Save a couple where you have to be careful.
Um,
so to that you have to be very careful about our anger and disgust.
So if,
um,
something about you is,
is disgusting to me,
but I still want a relationship with you,
I probably should suppress that one.
Um,
Eh,
I probably should be able to control my anger.
In some recent research I did with Ed Lemay and Nicola overall,
we found that it's much better if you do something dreadful to me.
Um,
for relationship it's better to express hurt and anger hurts suggests that I
still have hope that you'll,
uh,
I'm unhappy with what you did,
but I still have hope you'll fix it.
Um,
if I'm angry,
that's more of a distancing emotion.
So I think the same things can produce hurt and anger in a person,
uh,
but expressing,
feeling and expressing curt is more constructive for a relationship.
Feeling and expressing anger is more likely to distance us from one another.
And do you ever think that one can express too much emotion,
whether it's some of these more,
perhaps a socially bonding emotions or,
or anger and disgust as well?
Can you ever express too much?
Oh,
absolutely.
Um,
so there are number of different circumstances.
So one time I shouldn't be expressing too much sadness,
fear,
or whatever is when you have pressing needs.
So there's sometimes when I ought to suppress it,
not because you don't care about me,
not because I shouldn't turn to you for your help,
but,
but you have more pressing needs.
Um,
and then I should be paying attention to your emotions and perhaps suppressing
mine.
Uh,
another time you can express too much emotion,
um,
is,
uh,
if,
if you persist in expressing the s say sadness.
So you're trying like crazy to make me feel less sad and nothing you do can make
me less sad at some point you're going to give up.
And so some people do that.
They,
they express a lot of hurt or a lot of sadness or a lot of anger and their
partner,
nothing.
The partner does changes it and then it's bad.
Um,
there's also another case where you can express too much emotion.
And I think it's something people don't think about.
It's,
it's a special case of what I would call exploitation in communal relationships.
So it involves exaggerating how much I feel amplifying my emotion,
um,
to get you to take care of me when I really ought not be doing that.
I'm,
I'm exaggerating it.
And I think people do that very commonly in communal relationships and it's not
good.
So I am so sad and down,
I can't possibly wash those dishes.
You should do it.
Um,
partners sometimes fall for that.
but they also sometimes pick up on that and resent it.
So that's another case.
Where are you going to express too much emotion?
In that case,
it sounds almost like it's inauthentic emotion,
right?
You're sort of overexaggerating it to extent that it could annoy your partner,
upset then they might feel you're being manipulative.
Right?
That's exactly what it is.
It's not uncommon and it's unique,
not unique,
but it's much more common in communal relationships and the exchange because an
exchange relationship,
if I'm said you're not responsible for it,
so it's not a good technique to manipulate you,
but in a communal relationship,
you're responsible for my sadness.
So I can take advantage of that.
I shouldn't,
it's bad for relationships,
but it's a uniquely communal kind of manipulation.
Fascinating.
One of the thing that's always interested me in your work too is that in some
relationships we keep track or tally certain favors or inputs.
And I,
you know,
I'm sure people out there wonder,
under what circumstances are and what relationships is that actually a good
thing versus something that could really hurt the relationship to be keeping
track of these things.
There was one of the first things I looked at in relationships and it's a good
thing to do,
uh,
in business relationships.
You really should keep track of your bills and you should pay them.
And if you don't keep track of the other person will.
But in communal relationships,
it's suggests that,
um,
it's,
it's bad for a number of reasons.
One is that it suggests that the reason you're providing support for a partner
is that you want something back.
Um,
and while that's fine in lots of kinds of relationships with partners,
really want and close relationships is for the reason you're giving them support
is that you actually care about them.
Um,
the other reason is it really bad is that it makes the QT giving a benefit is
either that you've received one in the past and you need to repay it or you want
something from the person in the future.
And,
uh,
that's interesting because,
if you're doing that,
the cue to providing support is not the other person's need or desire.
Um,
and it's important that the cue to giving support is the other person's need.
Desire.
Welfare doesn't mean these relationships are unselfish.
So I may form a relationship with you because I want a friend.
I want someone who'll be responsive to my needs.
That's pretty selfish.
Um,
but to get that kind of relationship,
there's a deal.
I have to be responsive to your needs,
watch out for your welfare.
And I can hope I can't require,
but I can hope that you'll,
uh,
feel the same.
Um,
and that you'll respond to my needs.
It may not all even out in the end.
Um,
but overall I think these kinds of relationships are beneficial to people.
Fascinating.
So when you think about relationships and how they play an important role in our
emotional wellbeing and how emotions influenced the social relationships,
where do you see the next steps or where do you see the future of this research
headed?
Well,
every researcher is course by us to think the future should capture what they're
interested in.
And I'm no exception to that.
So I think that we do need to study relationship emotions,
not just emotions,
all kinds of phenomenon.
I think we need to study in relational context that,
um,
right now we're doing.
A good example would be say,
emotion regulation.
We do now know thanks to a lot of work by James Gross a lot about how
individuals,
uh,
regulate their emotions and it's important work.
But we also need to know,
uh,
when we do that for ourselves and when we rely on partners to do it for us.
And I think we often do rely on partners to regulate our emotions.
We're exhausted,
we're sad.
And uh,
sometimes the partner takes over.
They're the ones who distract us from our emotion.
They're the ones who reappraise it.
Tell us it's not so bad and explain exactly why it's not so bad.
We don't know a lot about how partners regulate one another's emotions.
I'm confident that they do.
Um,
we don't know a lot about how relational context influences the,
the,
the very nature of the emotion you express,
the amount of the emotion,
new express.
So I would say,
uh,
one important direction to go in.
The one I'm particularly interested in is putting our understanding of emotions
in relational context.
Hmm.
And so when you think about putting our emotions in a relational context and
you're talking to students who are interested in embarking in studying emotion
or relationships more generally,
what kind of advice do you give them?
Well,
I think you need to,
uh,
whenever you're looking at the intersection of two fields and now it is the case
that emotion research is largely separate still from relationship research
conferences get held on the two things and they don't have a membership of the,
of the groups that go to those conferences don't overlap.
Um,
but what's important to as a student is probably to study both areas and that,
um,
and then think for yourself about how they intersect and bring the two fields
together.
There'll be insights from each one that will,
you can apply to the other one.
So that can be done by intentionally reading both literatures,
by having mentors in both fields,
by going to both kinds of conferences.
There's lots of ways to do it,
but whenever you study two different areas of research,
um,
and you're thinking about them close in time,
you'll see connections.
And I think you can build on those connections.
That's,
that's a great thing to think about connecting different fields to really answer
the questions that are most important to you.
Yeah.
Well,
another thing you can do,
I think,
um,
is if you're studying emotion,
you can ask yourself a very simple question,
which is,
are there any situations in which whatever effect was observed would not be
observed?
Um,
and you can ask that question specifically about relational contexts,
but you can ask it in other ways as well.
I think that's often a way you can think of new ideas to do research on,
is just to say,
do I believe this always occurs for everybody in every context?
And almost certainly the answer's gonna be no.
Well,
thank you so much for being with us today,
Peggy.
Um,
this concludes our experts in immersion interview with Doctor Peggy Clark from
Yale University.